this is casual blitz against rocky let's
get some sounds speech speech synthesis
right knee goodbye game start before
yeah good bye people
I played rocky a couple times before
okay let's play d5 I just want to check
the time control oh it's five over 35
Edie 529 696 we might have I don't say
we might have a Scandinavian or L we may
have an Icelandic horses a Scandinavian
but we're gonna have a Portuguese wait
what just happened
Bishop g4 Bishop g4 here we go yeah this
is a Portuguese variation starting with
Bishop Bishop e2 I'll take on you -
bishop take C - and then Queen takes to
unite takes it to Queen takes d5 now I'm
hitting the pawn on on G - I'm just
ready to play knight c6 maybe castle
Queen seven short Castle knight c6
[Music]
yeah I want to make it sharp 90 c3 yeah
let's play Quidditch five Queen h5
there's a possibility that will trade
Queen's very soon
you 693 yeah mmm my treat
I'm so sorry
thanks for letting you know about that
let's not treat Queens
it's like Queen h4 Queen h4 hopefully
that's better now I just I move the
trackpad so I'm I'm avoiding the Queen
trade there's some risk to this but
there's also a potential reward d5 d5
like a Castle queenside wait why right
castle long castle here we go trying to
pin pinning the pawns of the Queen you
say also had 9595 might come very soon
b6 is probably the media threats Queen
f3 u Queen I've 395 o 95 Queen I 5
there's a slight issue let's play Knight
e4 Knight d4 kind of tricky move hitting
the Queen hitting c2 pawn if Queen d3 I
have a 5
Queen b3 yeah probably five e 5y two
minutes 57 seconds
mm-hmm black three minutes 48 seconds
hidden Knight f5 oh wow I could take it
yeah there's actually kind of
interesting trapped
let's take it Knight takes them in my
flicking me ace Queen takes f5 check
King b8 I'm losing my e-pawn Queen takes
e5 this policy of g5 but that would have
been part of the trap
Bishop g5 of tricky move I've queen h5
queen h5 essentially pinning the bishop
to the Queen now I'm threatening h6 it's
getting a little bit weird
what could still take on honey v h3 but
yeah why is not 2 but now each 6 H 6
okay g4 how would you for the Queen g5
Queen takes g5 yeah Queen takes g5 I'm
just up a bishop h g5 h takes g5 yeah
and now each file is open I'm hitting
the pawn with the rook from Age 3 ad1
Brooke a t1 flip on stolen d5 so I can
just take on on each three i think--for
oh no not wreckage for one tiger cage 3
you still here ooh what if that's Hoggy
Hoggy is just summoning himself King G -
G - yeah I miss my chance play Bishop d6
Bishop d6 so I have an eye on you no no
f6 for rock dh8 rook tha okay expecting
h1 what and Saybrook a3 I can't I can't
replay it huh that's weird
I just played Bishop takes 83 what just
happens
died mess something up shift happens
[Music]
I've I can't move anything
oh it just game start what game start
what well I'm just confused what's going
on what it's something broke whoa wait
what John just gave 10,000 bits because
because togi is maybe still here wait
what's over t3 so I broke it because I
gave away Bishop - well do i what do I
do now I don't know what to do
d4 okay wait no I'm gonna turn off the
sound or no let's go pentatonic and
let's play this move yeah there's
there's some kind of whoa it's Charlie
again
maybe John crashed it with all the bits
oh dear we all missed Augie sometimes
wait I wanted to
make this a bit more interesting this is
not looking so great but I have to do
this ah what am i doing okay
wait no I actually I'm in major trouble
here play this move then rook f4 okay
now we're gonna trade some more twenty
seconds
everything was lagging but I'm winning
pawns okay
material equals somehow let's activate
the King and then activate the I don't
think I can get away of taking okay oh
[Music]
yeah this is also the last game for me
hopefully we'll have a nice ending yeah
rook is almost trapped kind of maybe
I'll play c5 next maybe a3 next now
let's play this move yeah rook is very
close to being trapped in this move ah
it's annoying
[Music]
mmm this is difficult it's very
difficult no I wanted to take the rock
oh gosh
[Music]
yes well how will the finish was
ambassador finish haha so my soaked good
game rocky 35